people need to know that the shaking is
not over oh my god this is a massive
movie is the imax ultimate experience
it's a huge disaster okay on the imax
theater this whole chunk of land will be
decimated it's amazing set out to do
something that you see it you're like
wow that's like the good version of what
we wanted to do the earth will literally
crack open it's just an incredible huge
epic film we're going now
when the rock headlines movie is you're
in for a ride number one it was a
massive practical set the street would
break apart you know extra screaming it
was such a massive affair so I can only
guess how big the movies gonna do I
cannot emphasize this enough you need to
get out and I mean now the whole time
overriding is what we kept on saying was
a machinist in imax 3d it's made for
that i don't think there will be able to
expect what we give them it was like
nothing was to be go too crazy it's just
an incredible huge epic film hold on we
gotta get over before class
I've been saving more I was a nine